أجنبي
ماذا تعرف عن برنامج
Reckless Mystery Men الذي ترسله يا رفاق
عندما يمكنك صيد
Netflix الأجنبي
[موسيقى
] يجب أن يكون Lloyd الذي أعطاها
سلة المهملات Dash فقط إنها تميل إلى Lloyd
[Music]
أولاً وقبل كل شيء تهانينا  لقد
استمتعت حقًا بمشاهدة هذا الفيلم ، لقد
فشلت في ركوب قطار الملاهي ، ما مدى الإثارة التي
كان تصويرها جيدًا للغاية ، لقد حصلت على
ريان جوسلينج وهو يركل مؤخرته ويفعل ما
يفعله جيدًا حقًا هذا النوع من
الدور البطولي مع الروس
وأه دعم Netflix
ولديك شارب رائع ، نعم ، أعلم أن
الحركة الرائعة هي مشاهد الحركة الأكثر أصالة
التي شاهدتها على الإطلاق ،
وتعرف أن هذه قصة جيدة حقًا
عن أنك تعرف أناسًا حقيقيين
وبقلب كبير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لتضعها  ضربة كبيرة على رأس ولدك
لا تعرف الاستعجال في مطعم
Hollywood
John Page حيث جيسيكا هينويك فيليب
شكرًا لك أي شخص
نراه هوليوود اليوم إنها أكثر تنوعًا
كما نرى ممثلين عرب ليسوا في
الشخصية النموذجية  الذين اعتادوا
اللعب قبل أن نرى الأمريكيين الأفارقة
نرى نوعًا مختلفًا من الأشخاص من جميع
أنحاء العالم ، ما رأيك في
هوليوود اليوم أكبر وأكثر تنوعًا أعتقد
أننا وصلنا إلى النقطة التي أصبح فيها هذا
أكثر شيوعًا  كما تعلم
، أعتقد أن الأمر يعود إلى صانعي الأفلام
والاستوديوهات والمديرين التنفيذيين وأنت
تعلم أنه يمكننا أن نثبت ويمكننا
إظهار ما يمكننا فعله إذا
أعطينا التغيير فقط
[الموسيقى]
وربما لا أحد
[الموسيقى  ]
عندما أرسلت لي السيناريو ، كنت
في منتصف تصوير فيلم أكشن
وقلت لوكيلي عن القطعة التالية
، أريد أن أجلس أو
أقف طوال الوقت بدون قتال ، لا يركض ، لا
يقفز شيئًا ، وقالوا هنا
اذهب ها هو الرجل الرمادي الذي سجلته
في أكبر حدث في العالم ، أكبر حدث
وكنت مثل هل تمزح
ثم قرأته أعتقدت حسنًا ، أعني
أنني يجب أن أقرر أن تذهب ،
شكرًا
لك ، الإجراء مذهل تمامًا في
هذا الفيلم  أخبرنا عن التدريب
والأبحاث التي تم إجراؤها مسبقًا على إطلاق هذا
المشروع ، تلقيت تدريبًا مجنونًا على هذا
الرجل الرائع بالمر الذي كان
مدرب أسلحتي ، نعم ، لقد كانت خلفيته أه
في دلتا فورس وهو ما
اخترناه للشخصية
أيضًا وكان مثل هذا  عملية
رائعة مثل تجربة كل هذا وتعلم
كيفية التعامل مع كل هذه
الأسلحة وأشعر بالقوة وشعرت أنني
أعرف ما كنت أفعله ثم كل الأعمال
المذهلة التي تعرفها عن تصميمات الرقصات
والبروفات مع الأخبار وريان
وكنت تعلم أنه كان شيئًا لا ينتهي
كان الأمر كما لو كان أكثر وأكثر ،
ثم نعم ، شكرًا جزيلاً لكم يا رفاق.